as promised I am bringing you guys
animating I've wanted to do for quite
some time I'm going to of course do my
regular new release reviews and my
hilarious ''tis and all that as well but
every once in a while I want to talk to
you guys about good anime films and
television shows just like I mentioned I
was gonna start doing in my previous
video why anime is important when I was
at Best Buy recently I picked up wolf
children this movie is directed by
Mamoru Hosoda I tried my best with that
hopefully I didn't screw that up he also
directed summer Wars and the girl who
left through time also really good
movies wolf children is about a woman
who falls in love with the man who is
secretive about something in particular
he's actually been hiding the fact that
he can transform into a wolf at will
anytime throughout his entire life he's
not a werewolf though he doesn't go
around eating people and tearing up
rabbits and stuff he just has this
affliction it's something that has been
with him ever since birth and he's one
of the last people in fact he is the
last person in his line and when stuff
kind of happens eventually she gives
birth to two children and they as well
have this similar wolf gene she has to
try to erase them and of course with
that comes a lot of problems because how
do you care for a child medically if
they have an issue what if they turn
into a wolf when they're on the medical
bed you know all these problems arise
she has to move far away to this very
rural country and learn how to be a
farmer to raise her two children and
basically teach them about life while
also not really knowing anything about
this other side of her kids this was a
breathtakingly beautiful movie I loved
every second of this film a lot of it
did remind me of having Miyazaki's
animation the background animations are
so lush and beautiful the storyboarding
was obviously set up so well because the
shots in this movie are absolutely
stunning but the best part about this
anime is that it actually is able to
take a kind of odd story when you really
think about it you're like I don't know
about some of those details in there
about how that actually happened and I
was able to get very invested in it to
the point of extreme emotion being
involved they do an excellent job at
setting up the main character for this
movie because you really start to care a
lot for her because she has
so much on her plate because she's a
mother who's caring for two children and
she really doesn't know anything about
half of them because when they turn into
wolves they can still talk and run
around and they tear up her house but
she doesn't understand that animalistic
side of them and so she has to find a
way to raise her kids amongst this world
in which everyone can look at them and
make fun of them and treat them as
outcasts if their secret comes out so a
definite theme of this movie is
definitely keeping a secretive side of
yourself and being afraid to be yourself
around other people and that's certainly
not an original theme of any kind that's
in tons and tons of movies especially
for younger audiences but this isn't a
movie really aimed at kids this is
actually a movie for all ages but I can
see adults loving this movie because you
can really relate to it if you have kids
I'm sure so not only is the animation
absolutely stunning I mean it really is
it's fluid it's vivid it's bright is
beautiful the blu-ray looks fantastic
but the dialogue between the mother and
her children was also so well realized
because a lot of it just felt very
incidental there are moments in the film
where you just see the mother learning
how to be a farmer she's learning how to
plow and till her field properly and
there's nothing epic or amazing about it
you're just watching a character
struggle to provide for her children and
I found that very very heartwarming is
easy to look at this movie and think
it's just going to be super cheesy very
melodramatic but it doesn't hit any of
those notes in fact there are moments in
this movie that were so emotionally
powerful to my mouth I actually dropped
a little bit because it just hit you
sometimes with this very powerful
imagery that you weren't expecting in
this type of film but kids can enjoy it
as well because it definitely has a lot
of really good lessons for kids and
adults can enjoy it because it has a
very mature outlook on the way you might
raise a child and the difficulties that
come along with that
I loved wolf children it's my favorite
anime film I've seen so far this year if
you have a chance to see it definitely
seek out the blu-ray or the DVD I'm
giving this film and a if you are a fan
of anime definitely check this film out
if you're not give it a try I really
think you'll enjoy this movie especially
if you like animation I will continue to
do my best to bring you guys more anime
reviews in the future I like my review
of sex tape up soon as always guys
thanks so much for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
I also wanted to let you guys know that
my promotion that I'm running currently
through audible.com is still going on
these guys contacted me and wanted me to
let you guys know that through them you
can get an audio book of your choice for
free if you go to audible.com slash
Chris there's absolutely no obligation
if you guys enjoy reading like I do but
you don't have a lot of time to open up
a book and do it you can use your tablet
your mp3 player your computer wherever
you are you can check out any audiobook
that's available at audible.com slash
Chris for free they have a lot of great
people narrating these books as well so
please check out audible.com slash Chris
for a free audiobook download and I want
to give them a big thanks because
they've done such a nice thing
sponsoring my videos and I'm very
grateful for that so thanks very much
guys